It actually benefits us when we let our
our legal system and our institutions
degrade. It actually benefits us. Are
you an accelerationist?
>> There's nothing bad faith about it. You
just can't contend with the arguments
>> that you that is that shows how small
your mind is that you think I can't
contend with that. IT IS A [laughter]
>> WHAT CREATORS do you watch that hand you
this slop and send you into the world?
Cuz clearly you would never have thought
of that on your own.
If I go to the wick panel, [music] this
was a this was a soy pill versus some
guy panel. Okay. [laughter]
At the soy pill, desperately calling for
backup, Pisco Litty comes charging to
the rescue. Will it be enough? Oh. Oh,
was Soy Bill getting destroyed? Was Soy
Bill did Soy Bill get obliterated?
Oh,
I guess I'll watch and see if that's
actually what happens. I I would love to
see. We'll watch a little bit off the
bat to get a flavor and then I might
jump forward to where the content comes
in. Okay.
>> What should the liberal response be to
the Trump administration apparently
subpoenaing subpoenaing Hassan [__]
What should our stance uh be on the US's
relationship with countries like Cuba?
I'm going to hand the mic first to Mr.
Soyill and then we'll let Bishop uh
introduce himself. So Soy Pill, go
ahead. What are your thoughts?
>> Uh it's irrelevant what his his behavior
is. It's pretty irrelevant to me if he
even did break a law here because what
seems obvious to me is this is an
>> it's so easy to understand actually we
should uphold our norms around enforcing
you know freedom of speech, freedom of
interaction, freedom of transaction,
freedom of association, right? We should
uphold these norms and these like these
things. We shouldn't punish somebody who
is trying to go and help people, right?
That those aren't liberal values. Those
aren't my values to just laugh when one
of your enemies is jailed. Well, hey,
how do you know you won't be jailed for
that same thing? You go to do something
kind. You go to do a nice thing and
people who are malicious want to
weaponize that against you.
What happened to being a a regular human
being, a good a good person? What
happened to that? Administrative
crackdown trying to introduce some sort
of chilling effect. They're not applying
the standard over every single person
that was on that uh convoy. They're not
doing it to their own partisan pundits
like Nick Shirley who might have stayed
in a sanctioned hotel. This is just an
attack to try to silence critics and you
should look at it as a fascist
government and an authoritarian move and
oppose it regardless of who they're
doing it to. Yeah.
>> Okay. Glad to have you and $10 from
pondering politics to say askill the
steel man Joe's definition of populism.
Uh we'll say that for the maybe the uh
the meat of the discussion, but uh
thanks for being here. We're going to
get into it as we go. Uh next up, we're
going to give the mic to Mr. Bishop. Go
ahead.
>> Hey everybody, it's [clears throat]
Bishop here. Self-described locky
liberal. Um I uh I do a I'm a defense
contractor by day and a poster on
Twitter by night. Um and uh my take on
the Hassan situation is that um I I
believe that a lot of the uh a lot of
the dialogue around Hassan right now is
talking about the illegitimacy of the
government and the illegitimacy of like
obviously in my opinion a fascist type
government uh and uh unwieldy uh use of
our institutions. However, I still think
that it's very important that we don't
throw out the baby with the bathwater
and um and just completely discredit any
any kind of a subpoena put out by
federal law enforcement. Um, and I think
the the point that I think really needs
to be argued,
>> oh, so this guy's going to argue
something. It's like, okay, maybe
there's a actual underlying like
fundamental purpose there, sure, but
like we'd have to see some evidence of
that, right? I don't mind that. I don't
mind that the people look into this
maybe,
but the way the media is jumping on it
and the way the government hasn't
cleared anything up or hadn't cleared
anything up, that seems concerning to
me.
>> And with that, I guess we'll get into
it. Can can you give us uh maybe
elaborate a little bit more on that
serious cause? Do we think that the
subpoena may be legitimate? What what
are your thoughts on that? Go ahead.
>> I think the question is what is
legitimate and what is illegitimate? I I
believe that now in the year of 2026
what we have across many different legal
domains is we have a series of rules,
regulations and laws. And uh what we
wind up having is we wind up having
situations where people will break a law
and then maybe they'll be pursued and
said, "Okay, well now we're going to
hold you accountable. You did break the
law." But the problem is that nobody is
prosecuted for that law. And so I think
one of the main ways people are looking
at this is they're like, "Oh, well maybe
Hassan violated sanctions, but number
one, I we don't know if we agree with
the sanctions in the first place. And
number two, uh like what we're seeing
with this Turning Point USA kid, we it
doesn't appear that the violations of
these sanctions are being applied
evenly. Therefore, it is targeted." And
um while I think that there is certainly
some truth in the unequal application of
of those uh violations, it really brings
me to think about the situation with Al
Capone. And don't get me wrong, I do not
think that Hassan,
>> Dude, if you mention Al Capone in
reference to Hassan. Oh, well, he's
really bad, so let's get him on
something. Listen,
dude.
Uh,
I we just all need to remember, okay?
Anybody who's taking this position, I
want to say anybody who's taking this
position where you are claiming to be a
liberal, but you're denigrating your own
principles to go after Hassan because
you think he's bad, you don't like him.
Anybody who's doing that, man, I feel
like I'm not gonna I'm not going to shed
a tear when it comes to you. I'll
probably fight it. I'll probably say
it's wrong, but I'm not I'm certainly
not going to shed a tear. I'll say
that's wrong. That's wrong. No, don't do
that. I'll probably say it more
forcefully. I'll probably just totally
caning actually defend the person it
happens to. But my god, these people
suck, man. I I will probably because
it's just what you have to do
ultimately. That's the position you have
to have is oh these people are using the
government to go after people and
they're they're basically breaking with
norms, breaking with rules to do it.
They are violating all the norms that
exist. They are not applying the law
evenly. And if I support that even in
the case of somebody I despise,
then it can be used against me. Although
not me because I live in another
country, but it could be used against
you.
And so don't think of it as protecting
that person you hate. Think of it as
protecting yourself or your loved ones.
That's who you're protecting when you
stand up for Hassan [__] Your loved
ones, not you. Sorry, not Hassan. You're
standing up for yourself, your loved
ones, your colleagues.
Do you get it?
How hard is this to understand? Is
Alapone. I want to be clear. Alapone
killed people. Hassan is just a
streamer. Um, but we understand that the
way they went after Alapone, the way
they got him was for tax evasion. And we
understand that he he wasn't targeted by
the IRS that the IRS was randomly like,
"Oh, hey, we think this guy might have a
problem with his taxes." The problem is
he was causing all these other problems
and taking advantage of all these
loopholes with with the liberties that
are afforded in a liberal society as
opposed to an authoritarian state. He
was taking advantage of them. And so we
understand that they had to do they had
to apply some of these rules that he was
breaking to address the greater problem
which was to get him off the street. Now
I I say all this,
>> don't you feel like totally insane? a
guy who abetted like dozens and dozens
and dozens of murders, all kinds of
crimes across like the the entire
Midwest. And you're like, "Yeah, that's
basically like Assad [__] We we need
to get Hassan [__] so badly off the
street so badly that we need to just
like fundamentally shift away from all
norms to do it." Like, I don't know. Why
would you Okay, you argue that you
better argue to go after Trump. You
better basically be arguing that like
Trump needs to be gone day one, right?
Come on, man.
the threshold, the legal threshold for
it to be a criminal is actually
outrageously high. So, I don't think
we're even really at that level. But I
do think that um the uh the hostile
nature of the Cuban government and the
Cuban island is unbelievably like uh not
talked about. A lot of people talk about
Cuba as if, oh, it's just another island
down there and we had like a shaky past
with them. But to
>> this already, this started off totally
insane that this guy like basically
makes an argument where he's like, "Oh,
well, you know, maybe there's an
argument that they're applying the law
unevenly and maybe this is like really
up." But also, if you considered Al
Capone,
you got to know that you are in an
argument. Okay, if if what Wick said is
true and Soy Pill is truly getting his
his blown out and he had to call for
help from Pisco,
that seems kind of tragic. That seems
kind of embarrassing. I hope that's not
the case, man. I sure hope not
>> to not go on and on and on. Um the fact
of the matter is according to uh Hassan
the the trip was organized with the
Cuban government. So this was a Cuban
government approved political program
and uh in it being a political program
that means that the uh Cuban military
and intelligence services were somewhat
involved. Even if that means that their
involvement was we approve uh it means
that they were involved and I I think
that's uh way more serious than
anybody's talking about right now.
>> Yeah. Uh so a few things. My
understanding is not only did he approve
this with the Cuban government cuz yeah
know you have to let the government know
before you take a giant ship full of 20
tons of supplies and drive it up to
their border. So of course they let them
know. He also went through OFAC the
office of foreign assets commission or
whatever that stands for. So he's went
through the same government that is
subpoenaing him right now. So the idea
that this is like some Cuban coordinated
back deal to subvert American interest
is pretty ridiculous to me. Uh the
second thing is this subpoena isn't so
it's going to be one of those debates
where they found somebody to argue
totally insane and obviously there's
only one person arguing like dude get
somebody in here who can actually argue
cuz holy like this isn't going to be a
debate. It's just going to be this guy
making a total ass of himself the entire
time making zero good points. You know
what I mean? Like this guy's just going
to continuously embarrass himself. At
least let Wick 2v1 at least. I hope Wick
at least 2v1's with against Soy Pill
because otherwise soy just gets to sit
back and be like, "Yeah, uh, so here's
like the fundamental thing we all
believe in and I don't know why I even
have to point this out." And the other
GUY'S LIKE, "WELL, HAVE YOU considered
that Al Capone is kind of like Hassan
Piker?" No, that's a totally insane
thing. I didn't consider that because
it's a completely insane thing to say. I
didn't entertain that or consider it
because you'd have to be on mushrooms to
consider that. You'd have to be on acid.
you would have to be out of your mind on
drugs to consider that. So, I didn't
consider it cuz I'm sober right now.
Isn't alleging a crime even. It's just,
hey, let's go after you by looking into
you, assuming that you did something
bad, but we're not sure yet. Which is
very clearly like, let's, you know, try
to investigate this person to produce
some sort of chilling effect. And third,
you did this whole alapone thing. Uh,
well, what's the alapone equivalent that
Hassan is doing right now that is like,
well, this guy's doing something illegal
that we can't get him through and it's a
loophole, so let's go after him. The
thing he's doing is talking [__] about
the government. He's about Democrats.
He's on Trump and you do not like that,
and that's fine. I don't like some of
the stuff he says, and in fact, I don't
like a lot of the stuff he says. But I
would never say, and this is why we need
to find some sort of legal loophole
like, "Hey look, you put 55 in a 50
zone. Let's lock him the up." That
doesn't justify. So, what do you think
justifies what he's doing right now that
the Cuban government colluded with him
to subvert American interest or some
sort of insane, you know, like back deal
here that you think is actually worth
arresting this person over or what he's
doing outside of this that this side not
real like thing, but this like side
project to arrest him is worth arresting
him over?
>> Well, let's let's start off with some
ground ground terms here. We're not
talking about a legal loophole. A lot of
people are using a lot of this loose
language to talk around the issues. This
is not a loophole. I went to Cuba
personally and when I went to Cuba I
kept a notebook with me and I documented
every single thing that I did because
the the legal uh permissions that I went
to Cuba with asan noted are very strict
and guess what when I came back I was
questioned on it. This is not some legal
loophole that somebody is, oh well,
technically everybody's it's 55. It's
actually very serious. And going to an
island that is actively involved in
military and intelligence operations is
perhaps the most aggressive intelligence
entity uh addressing the United States
consistently houses.
>> Oh, so if you've got an aggressive
intelligence agency that operates in the
United States, you'd want to like
basically treat that that entity like a
hostile entity, like not an ally at all.
Oh well.
Well, well, well. Let's see if this is
applied evenly in this conversation.
>> Chinese and Russian intelligence
facilities. Um, this isn't this isn't a
joke. And by the way, to put this into
comparison because like I said, we keep
on talking over Cuba like, "Oh, it's
it's just like some interest. It's just
some interest." If somebody went to
Russia and started uh spending money at
Russian militaryowned premises and then
they came back and they said, "Hey,
we're going to look into whether you you
violated any sanctions." I don't think
anybody would be freaking out about it.
In fact, I think most people would be
saying, "Hey, wait, what? You spent
money on a Russian military?"
Wait, but that's isn't that way
different that they cleared the whole
trip with the American government
beforehand? Isn't it like a way
different situation organization? Maybe
we should look into it. And like you
said, I think it's right. Number one,
from
>> look into it for what what's the
>> to see if to see if uh well, I think the
risk here is that he is collaborating
with Cuban uh intelligence uh
intelligence apparatus. I mean, one of
the main things uh one of the main
things that he said when he uh and one
of one of the main things we were
talking about that he said was that the
Cuban government reached out to him
through an intermediary about having
consistent internet access. So, but like
through an intermediary who would be a
FAR agent, I assume like somebody who
could lobby or somebody who could
represent the Cuban government. Like I I
thought this was literally somebody
through like OFAC. No.
>> What is going on with him having
consistent military a consistent uh
internet access and consistent power
access on an island in the middle of a
blackout? Was that a military network?
Was that a military generator? And if he
was on the military network, what if all
the FBI wants is possession of his
laptop to start going through the
records of getting to the bottom of uh
the details of that military uh int
military internet network? There's
there's like 20 dozen different things
here and Assad himself has said and this
really seems to be the case. He is not
the target. He doesn't think he's the
target. I don't think he's the target.
It seems like it honestly it seems like
Code Pink isn't even the target. It
seems like the target might be whoever
the main financial backers are of Code
Pink. And to sit here and say that an
intelligence agency has absolutely no
interest in a uh in a series of
influence operations that are addressing
ongoing military conflicts, I don't I
don't understand how we can sort of live
in that world where it's like why would
the FBI interest?
>> So this to me is one of those things
where people will look at the laws on
the books or immigration and say, "Well,
of course they broke the law. Don't you
think they have an interest in
investigating the laws that they broke?"
And you're kind of deferring to like
these laws that exist, which by the way
haven't always existed and changed
significantly under Obama and then were
reversed in 2017. And then to say that
this is not some sort of agenda-driven
thing to me is belying the point that
this is clearly an agenda driven thing
and whether or not they're targeting
Hassan Copink. The point of this is to,
you know, use them as this sort of
surrogate for we're attacking Cuba and
and the conversation right now is being
centered on should Hassan get in trouble
for this. If you think there's a good
faith effort by an intelligence agency
to go through Hassan's computer to find
potential adversarial information, maybe
this is to totally possible. Do you
think that's why he's being centered at
at these articles? Do you think that's
why the conversation is centered
entirely around him and not what you're
saying? because you're giving the most
good faith possible interpretation of
what an administration might be doing,
which is to me absolutely ridiculous
given everything we've seen come out of
the Trump administration. Like you would
have to be delusional to say anything
like this is that unless it's on paper
and ignoring the last 8 years of Trump
that we've seen.
>> Well, one one of the things that I I
when I listen to you and a panel of
people speak about this on live and
learn, I I noticed that everybody's
initial response was well, this is
coming out of the Trump administration,
so we immediately need to completely
discredit it. And while I think that uh
large political things coming from the
Trump administration warrant
>> I will I will get to it. Okay.
>> Serious scrutiny. they weren't seriously
uh sec going back over some things. I
think it's utterly ridiculous to live in
a world where we don't like the
president so we're just going to
discredit literally everything that
happens from the government period
because there's no real difference.
>> What what's what else is being
discredited right now? It's just saying
hey you're going after like some kind of
influencer and that's not even the case
by the way. I just think right now I
don't know what the government is doing.
I do think it's okay to meet the Trump
administration scrutiny of opposition to
their party with total like derision
with with you assume it's false until
they show why they're doing it. That is
the most appropriate way to handle it
because they've been shown to be bad
faith actors in so many cases. You know
what I'm saying?
>> I I mean that's essentially army. You
said they've got to be delusional to
>> what what information do you think that
they'll get out of Hassan's laptop that
they couldn't get through the entire
military intelligence apparatus that
they're already doing with spying?
Intercepting communications. Why do you
think they're subpoenaing specifically
Assan and Code Pink? And why do you
think these people the ones being
highlighted by Fox News, which by the
way happened before Assan or Code Pink
have confirmed they even got a subpoena?
So, this is a sensationalized article to
try to get ahead of something that might
not have even happened yet. Maybe it's
going to happen or maybe it never will
happen, but let's say it will. This is
meant to drum up anti, hey, look at
these leftwing people sentiment clearly.
Right.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. Yeah. So, I one
of the things that we're talking about
here is like is this politically
targeted? And it reminds me about
conversations when people talk about
terrorism. Oh, well, it's such a
political thing about what is terrorism
and what isn't terrorism. Terrorism by
definition is political. So of course
it's political. So this dialogue about
like oh well the only reason
>> uh this guy is just trying to talk in
circles
>> brother.
>> They're targeting Assan is because he
went to Cuba because there's a huge
military confrontation with Cuba right
now. It's like yeah that's
>> okay but you're immediately be
confronted with the fact that they did
not go after Nick Shirley in the same
way.
>> And so explain that discrepancy.
>> How things work when you that's not what
I'm alleging. I'm alleging they're going
to sign because he's a leftwing
streamer, not because he went to Cuba,
right? Nick Shley went to Cuba. He went
to a sanctioned hotel.
>> Yeah. So stupid, man.
Am I just going to watch this guy punch
himself in the face repeatedly for the
next hour?
>> Tell and they're not subpoenaing him to
my knowledge.
>> For sure. And I think it's very clear
that they are not going after Nick
Shirley because Nick Shirley is friendly
to the regime. But they are not going
after Hassan just because he's leftwing
because if they were, they'd be going
after every single major leftwing
commentator that didn't go to Cuba.
They're going after Hassan because he's
connected. He's low hanging fruit. He's
connected to code pink who has
>> didn't go to Cuba. That's the whole
that's the whole reason they're able to
have this excuse to go after them.
They're going after other people that
went on the flotilla or the convoy that
went to Cuba and they're using that as
an excuse. Obviously, it's not relevant
that they went to Cuba. But this is what
they're using as the like, oh, and this
is why we're allowed to go after, right?
Just like the your example with Alapone.
It's like, well, you did this. Now we
have an excuse to punish.
>> That's another great point. You
literally brought up Al Capone to make
an example of you, right? You you
brought up Al Capone. Why would you
bring up Al Capone if you don't know if
you don't in some way like totally
understand what's happening here? Why
did the name Al Capone even leave your
lips, bro?
>> Right.
>> Yeah. And and absolutely. I think like I
don't understand where the confusion
here is. There's sort of like some
allegation that something nefarious is
going on because people collaborate.
>> What could Soy just ask him why he
brought up Al Capone? I just need to
know why did you bring up Al Capone?
What was the context? What were you
trying to deliver to me? What
information were you attempting to help
me understand when you brought up Al
Capone?
>> With the Cuban government and by
definition with how it works, the Cuban
military and intelligence apparatus to
go on a political trip for the purposes
of politics and then they're being
investigated upon it in what world.
>> Wait, so name something that doesn't
apply to Nick Shirley right now. Name
something that doesn't apply. I assume
if you're an American going to Cuba, you
got to clear a bunch of either with OFAC
or with the Cuban government. you know,
just to get to go is like a non-Cuban
citizen to Cuba as an American, right?
And never clear anything with them.
That's crazy.
That Well, I mean, I feel like you'd be
taking a big risk doing that, right? You
take a bunch of camera equip equipment,
you smuggle yourself into Cuba. I feel
like you'd be taking a massive risk. No,
>> I mean, honestly, it would not justice
if they weren't investigated for it.
>> Do you think Do you think there's like
5% the Trump administration tried to let
Nick Shirley get smuggled to Cuba hoping
they just kill him? gives him like a
pretext to invade. [laughter]
>> I'm gonna skip forward. I'm skipping
forward.
>> Oh, getting rid of him, right?
>> By the way, um
>> who who are they dragging in?
>> I'll be honest. I'm gonna be honest with
you. And then maybe no one's going to
disagree with this. I feel like we don't
need to ban Hassan. We don't need to
feel bad for him either at all. And to
be honest, I don't even know why. I
mean, even if people do um cheer on it,
I don't think it's bad cuz Hassan is an
enemy of us as well. And they're not
going after like liberals, I would say.
So, I don't know there's any reason we
need to defend someone who will not
defend us. And if anything, getting rid
of him, I mean, quote unquote, getting
rid of him, right, would help us in the
long run anyway. So, if you look at like
a net benefit side, him being gone is
the great greatest thing ever. I'm not
going to defend
>> Wait, so Vicy, to be clear, you wouldn't
defend anyone for any sort of rights
that you think are like supposed to be
of enforced for all Americans if you
didn't like them.
>> No. Okay, that's a really Okay.
>> Do only disabled people call into Wick?
This guy is a total [__]
It actually benefits us when we let our
our legal system and our institutions
degrade. It actually benefits us. Are
you an accelerationist? What creators do
you watch that hand you this slop and
send you into the world? Cuz clearly you
would never have thought of that on your
own. That is a totally moronic argument
you just made. Whoever this guy is,
wrong with this person. Dude,
>> I would defend him if it was anything
like
>> that's a Hutch mod. Classic.
We don't have to feel bad for him.
Nobody's telling you to feel bad that
Hassan's getting arrested. What I'm
asking you to do is go hassan,
but I'll defend him anyway.
[__]
It sure is funny that that guy's getting
over, but I am going to step in and
defend him now because I don't want that
to happen to me. I'm gonna step into and
help him now because I don't want that
to happen to one of my friends. That's
what you do. You can laugh. You could go
haha, but I'm still going to defend him.
>> The Cuba thing, I feel like they have
some form of legal avenue to do it and
it could be yes or no. I don't think it
is straight up like just political. I
would say they literally advertised
something that could
>> Nobody said it was just Nobody said that
they made this up for no reason. Hassan
went to Cuba. They're saying they're
applying the law unevenly. When you come
in and say, "Well, he technically did go
to Cuba and stuff." Yeah, nobody's
disputing that. You are just wasting
time. You were just filibustering,
wasting time cuz you were a [__] it'
be sanctioned. What? Like sanction
breaking or whatever. But if it was like
for espionage or something like that,
I'll be like, "Okay, no, this is bad."
So
>> Well, then why do you have why do you
have any smoke? Dude, you can't make up
that. You can't make up that that guy's
a hutch. Holy [__] There's just there's
no way that's a hutch, dude. For Hassan
doing it at all then, if you would do
the same back cuz I think what he says
when he say he's like a, you know,
centrist Democrat getting arrested or
having some dumb DOJ charges thrown
under him, that's bad, right? And then
that's why I wouldn't do it to Hassan.
But you're saying, "No, actually, I I
won't have any smoke for a song cheering
on Adam Schiff getting arrested because
that's what I think we should do."
Right?
>> My problem with that argument is that
it's it draws a false equivalency. It's
sort of like, "Oh, yeah. You say you're
tolerant. Well, then why don't you
tolerate my intolerance?" And it's like,
"Look, the same thing from different
people are different things."
>> Yeah. One of them you agree with and the
other one you don't, but they're the
same tactic, which is I don't care what
the charge is. If this gets rid of them,
I'm okay with it. Right.
>> I just I just want to make my stance
clear here,
>> dude. It's so stupid, man.
I understand how you let like let like
your anger blind you sometimes. Maybe
I get it. I get how you can let your
anger blind you sometimes. It makes some
sense to me, but you got to you got to
wake up before you go on a debate panel
and like sober up and figure out what's
actually important. You know what I
mean? Like, oh, I really hate this guy.
Whatever. We keep watching.
>> I think that Vishy I I think that's the
wrong way to go about it and wrong way
to think about it. This isn't like, oh,
he didn't defend us. We shouldn't defend
him. No. The reason my mind changed is
because I was convinced and and and
reminded of because again I have worked
in the military before that there were
oh wow there's a plausible legitimate
reason that a subpoena could be issued
here that I think I cannot I do not have
enough information to say whether or not
my distrust of the Trump administration
overrides that. And so I am like okay I
think the legitimate reasons are enough
that I'm going to sit back stand by uh
see what happens here. I'm not going to
take too strong of a stance yet. Um, I
think subpoenaing him could very well be
entirely legitimate and within America's
interest. So, I'm just gonna Yeah, but
my my
>> that could all be true. You should still
say that, hey, this is bad. Hey,
investigating Hassan without like some
some very obvious pretext, some very
obvious reason why. I'm going to assume
this politically motivated, right? I
that could be totally fine. That could
be a reasoning for saying, "Well, I'm
very suspicious of this and I support
Assan. I don't think he should be jailed
for anything he's done." Right? Like I
don't think he should be in trouble for
anything he's done here. He took aid to
starving people. I don't want him
prosecuted for that in any way. But if
they want to look through it for some
sort of intelligence reason, okay,
that's fine with me.
>> I'm I'm kind of okay with that. I could
be more okay with that. Okay. Decision
here isn't because oh, Hassan didn't
defend us, so we're not going to defend
him. That's
>> that's not the main reason. I'm going to
put a part of it. It's like a minor
reason, but I'm going to have that in
there. Same way like I would say for the
>> Come on, please go. If you want in, jump
in, brother.
>> I was I wasn't mad. I mean, I was
extremely bad when he went after Comey,
even though I hate Comey with all my
heart because I feel like that was
straight up just like that was straight
up just political warfare. I think there
is some validity to going after Assan.
>> Like at the end of the day, I hate
Republicans more than I hate Assan. So
>> yeah,
>> at I was so mad at Comey cuz I feel like
I didn't see any single reason for them
to do it or any of those ex-Trump guys
that didn't like that didn't bend the
knee at the very end. They went after
him. I didn't like that even though I
can be like, "Oh, who cares, right?" Um
I think it's cuz they all went after one
single goal. Um, if I swear if this was
like another way they attacked us on for
something else, I'd be like defending
it. I just think there is validity here,
which is why I'm not going to feel which
I'm not even going to feel bad about. If
there is some validity
[__] up on her mortgage stuff,
>> to be honest, I don't know much about
it. I don't think she did.
>> Don't Don't say do you think she did?
Don't say that. Say, what if she did?
What if she did? Do you think it's
appropriate for the Trump government to
push through to push through a grand
jury, an indictment that the actual
attorney general or sorry, the actual uh
states attorney for that state didn't
want to bring? Do you think it's good
for them to push their finger down, put
their thumb on the scale and push that
indictment to happen,
right? Cuz let's say Leticia James did
actually something up there. But in a
way, a ton of people something up.
Should she be prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law, which is what they
wanted to do? They just completely made
it up. It was a total lie. It wasn't.
>> Oh, speaking of [laughter]
Pisco is going to go silverback mode on
this guy if he continues on this route.
Okay. Especially now that the Leticia
James thing has been brought up.
>> Like maybe they found an error
somewhere.
>> I mean, possibly. I don't know much
about it, so I'm not going to speak on
it. I don't want to do that. I don't
>> go look into it and then question
whether or not you do the same thing for
Leticia James given that like, hey,
wait, hold on. You did technically break
the law. It's fine. They're going after
her, right? Well, there's also a
difference in getting something wrong on
your mortgage paperwork and
collaborating with a hostile foreign
government to indoctrinate the American
public by the millions. There's
>> Wait, do you do you think that's what
they're subpoenaing for? Why would the
Why would OFAC be the ones subpoenaing
him if that was the concern? Are you out
of your mind? Why would Why would the
Office of Foreign Asset something I need
to remember what this is? Office of
Foreign Assets Control. Why would they
be the ones subpoenaing him if that was
the actual concern? Are you out of your
mind? Come on, man.
>> You haven't substantiated whatsoever.
But okay. Yeah.
>> Well, actually, hold on. Pisco, uh, or
soy pill, before you guys jump in there,
I actually have a a point.
>> Pisco, shut the up. Pisco sitting here
has not SPOKEN YET. PISCO, SHUT UP.
PISCO, shut the up. Pisco, stop over. Do
we know who funded the media network
that sponsored Hassan's trip to China?
Because I feel like
>> a billionaire named Singum.
>> Yeah. Do we know if this person has any
relation to who sponsored Code Pink for
the China flotilla or not the China
flotilla, the Cuba flotilla? Because in
reality, this might not be about Cuba at
all. This could be about ties to the
CCP, which is even more adversarial to
the US, which I would say is a much
stronger case, not necessarily against
Hassan, but would be a much more valid
reason for a subpoena. As far as the
>> So, what's the reason?
Wait, did somebody pay? These guys are
saying, are they implying there's like
Hassan's trip was paid for by somebody
else. Is there some evidence for this?
>> Pina leaking to Fox News, which I know
is what Soy Pill is about to say. I just
think that was somebody being
advantageous and selling a scoop to Fox
News and the administration for a few
thousand bucks because who the hell in
this administr
>> being advantageous
isn't getting rich on the public's dime
essentially.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Please go. Hold on. Just before we
go, please go. I got some uh stuff.
>> Oh, wait. A sponsor for the visas is way
different than a sponsor. A sponsor for
a visa doesn't pay you money. That's
like that's a name. That's a word, but
it doesn't mean sponsor in terms of
money.
>> Come on, man. Come on, dog.
>> You got some thoughts?
>> Yeah, a little bit. Yeah. I just don't
know what's wrong with taking a negative
inference against this administration.
Uh especially when it comes to, you
know, subpoenas and targets related to
political actions. Are we supposed to be
blind? ignore the course of conduct of
this administration as though they're
not I don't think anybody's argued that
>> hang on a second. So um I think when it
relates to
>> that's quite literally the argument when
you come and say well actually we don't
know if it's wrong yet that is the
argument you're making. Pisco is saying
give uh them a negative inference
immediately because everything they've
done so far has been totally corrupt and
totally your position of ignorance. I
don't really know maybe it is legitimate
is actually an argument against what
Pisco is saying
things like potential criminal
investigations at this point in the
administration. It is your duty to make
negative inference against what the
administration is doing to the extent
that it relates to you know politically
relevant topics or politically relevant
uh individuals. You could always say,
couldn't you, at the subpoenas they gave
to James Comey, for example, relating to
uh testimony he may have given to
Congress. Well, there's a potentially
plausible um legitimate purpose and
crime. Isn't it a crime to lie under
oath to Congress? I mean, that is a
crime, isn't it? And you cannot the
administration.
>> Well, who who are you directing this
towards? I'm kind of curious. I
>> I think Wick or you to somebody were
saying that it's improper to take a
negative inference against
administration. Nobody said that.
>> Quick, Bishop, please. Uh to be clear,
coming into this debate, I did and I
still have a negative um opinion of
this. Like I I came in skeptical because
anything the Trump administration does
deserves a high degree of skepticism.
However,
>> uh there has been
>> So what evidence has caused you to to
overcome what what is overcome your
skepticism, your negative inference?
What evidence is there that has overcome
this
>> been a great argument made by Bishop
that oh the Cuban government is a
hostile government and there are very
>> So you just didn't know before this. You
hadn't thought in that pretty little
brain of yours, Wick. Oh, well, the
Cuban government doesn't like America.
Apparently, that slipped Wick's mind.
Wick didn't even think about that. When
this entire argument was first being
made, Wick totally forgot that the Cuban
government is hostile to America.
Really? So, you're like a complete
You're like a slobbering worthless.
Okay, fantastic. I guess we already knew
that but proof
something may have gone on that the
America would have a interest.
>> I just totally forgot that like Cuba
doesn't like America that this guy made
an amazing argument and said that Cuba
doesn't like America and I was like oh
my god
maybe this is legitimate.
>> Yeah. Okay. Fantastic about So I think
>> Do you think that the Trump admin wick
is more likely to have what you just
described or everything they've been
displaying? It's a coin toss after
everything you've seen them do.
>> The difference between Comey indictment,
the Comey indictment we knew was because
the plausibility of Comey having done
what they said was almost zero. However,
the plausibility of the U of the Cuban
government and intelligence agencies
trying to use Hassan or get information
from Hassan that it would be within our
interest to find out what they asked him
or what they even talked to him about is
much much higher. Right.
>> What would it take to proper on that
view?
I guess if you always think that there's
a potential interest in the in the
>> So again, okay, you could say all of
that.
>> So they should be subpoening Nick
Shirley, right?
>> So again, the same investigation must be
carried out in Nick Shirley for the
exact same reason. Yes. Yes. If they are
ignoring that, if they're not doing that
investigation into Nick Shirley, then
something improper must be happening
here. If that was the only bar,
then surely ha then surely Nick Shirley
would be getting subpoenaed.
>> Government of United States to find out
what Cuba said or talked to about. What
would it take for you to be like
actually this is not good?
>> Well, if if uh as a result of their
subpoena, they uh do something like
charge him for uh buying a hot dog from
one of the sellers there, right? Then
that would be like, okay, this was
obviously and this shouldn't have
happened and this was obviously a
political attack. But however, all they
do is come in, ask them, "Hey, did you
talk to uh did you talk to this person?"
>> How about this? What did they ask?
>> No, hang on, hang on a second. No, I'm
I'm saying with respect to the subpoena
itself, put aside any So, are you saying
that only in the context in which or one
of the the key instance which you could
see yourself disagreeing with the
subpoena is if some charge comes out of
it? Um, but like is that are those
really the only circumstances under
which you would question the the use of
the subpoena itself as as a device?
>> I think it's because it's Cuba. If it
was like
>> Yeah,
>> this is Can I Can I real quick?
>> Go ahead. I apologize. Yeah. So, Pisco,
number one, I wanted to say I think
you're right fundamentally with what
you're saying. Perhaps uh you know, the
way that I've been wording it is
anything political coming out of this
administration warrants extra scrutiny.
I think that's absolutely true.
>> Oh, wait. That's not what I said. Sorry,
I didn't say extra scrutiny.
>> Negative inference. Their action should
be viewed as disfavorable, as not
legitimate until proven legitimate.
>> I said a negative inference to be
opposed to it unless and until you're
shown some strong evidence that's uh
motivated by non bias.
>> What do you What do you mean by negative
inference? By negative energy, I mean a
disposition that is against it, not just
extra scrutiny.
>> Yeah, you're like, you're sounding a lot
like an election denier to me. That's
just what that sounds like.
>> An election denier is not using a as a
basis for Pisu's opinion is all of the
corruption, all of the weaponization of
the system that's been done so far. The
election denier has
Dude,
[laughter] he's about to I hear it. I
hear it. He's He's He's fueling up.
Okay, he's he's getting into a rage. I
can feel it from here. I can feel the
the anger. Okay. Just I can feel it
radiating through my screen.
>> To me is you're just like automatically
you should assume that that's what it
sounds like to me.
>> It's not at all like
>> just automatically
>> go pieces but to tear this guy's arms
off
>> inference automatically we should
distrust the election and
>> hang on a second. So it is sometimes
rational to take a negative disposition
against a person or institution as a
default presumption. Yes or no?
>> That's so genuine. Sometimes
>> what do you mean what what do you mean
by inst Yeah.
>> should frame it as do you have a
principal position against ever saying
an institution shouldn't be trusted at a
fundamental level
>> like do you have some sort of position
where it's like I will always assume the
institution is acting in good faith
unless shown otherwise. If you have that
position then I don't need to argue
further.
>> Explain that more. I'd love to answer.
>> Yeah. So to disbelieve information
coming from a particular source until
shown corroborating evidence. It is
sometimes rational to have that
epistemic frame of reference. Yes or no?
Well, I I [laughter] don't think that's
very clear. I don't think it's clear. I
don't think it's clear what you're
saying because you are applying you are
applying this this uh warranted negative
inference to the Trump administration to
the actions of a subpoena from the FBI
and that that's a very wide net. Very
wide net whoever fine, whoever the sorry
the federal government. So I'm happy but
I just want to clear up the air because
you said that this is this would be like
taking a kind of negative inference
against election results and I'm trying
to first clear that up to make sure
there's no confusion. That's not at all
what I applied. So you this notion No,
just I just want to be clear about that.
It's not uh sort of included in my
criticism in my application of a
negative inference regardless of its
scope. It's not necessitated or entailed
that I would take that approach to
election results. Correct.
>> So I don't know how wide your net is.
Like you're applying it to this this uh
organ this federal organization that
issued this subpoena. Like where do
where does it stop and start with this
Trump
>> so I'm happy to get into the scope and
and talk to you about that. But it's
just enough for you to say it's not
entailed that I take this epistemic view
and this negative inference in the
context of elections. Right. That's not
entailed.
>> I I I think it is entailed because you
haven't substantiated how wide your net
is.
>> Well, no, it's possible. It's it's
narrow such that it doesn't include
elections. Correct.
>> No, you haven't. You haven't
>> substantiated. Wait, wait. Sorry. You're
arguing with me, dude. I'm not asking.
Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I'm not I'm not
saying that I have substantiated. I'm
asking is it possible for one to have
this negative inference?
>> Possible. Yes. I'm asking you. This is
the third time. I'm asking.
>> So, I'm telling you asking four times or
five.
>> Yes. So, so what I'm telling you is I
don't have that view for election
results. Okay.
>> So, so that's what I'm trying to sus
out. So, is it just elections? Is it
just the dirty word? Is it just the one
that makes you sound stupid that you
don't agree with? Or is there a line
somewhere?
>> Why didn't Pio just say that there's
like a track record that I'm basing this
on? Did he not say that already? That I
have like an actual track record that
I'm basing this on, that this government
has come in and totally every norm and
rule that exists. Feels very easy to do
that.
>> No, no. The negative inference is makes
sense to apply whenever it makes sense
to apply it, right? To the extent that
it makes sense to apply it. It doesn't
make sense to apply it in the context of
elections. Yeah. So, it makes sense to
apply. That's what Sorry. That's what he
is saying. He's just saying it's
obvious. It's like self-evidently a
negative inference to
>> no peace code. This guy is like
slobbering on his he he like slobbered
on his keyboard and shortcircuited his
camera. You need to speak slowly for
him. You need to like lay it out very
slowly, very nicely. All right. Very
neatly, chill, and just lay out the
facts for this guy
>> to government actions or justifications
in the context in which the government
consistently lies and is corrupt. So in
that context it makes sense to apply
negative inference and that's not true
when it comes to election results
largely run by state governments.
Agreed.
>> No, I don't I fundamentally don't agree.
I think there's
>> uh [screaming]
what what do you Okay. So then show me
the corruption coming from state
governments.
Show me the like objective and and
easily viewable corruption coming from
the state governments in the same way.
>> State governments are different
sovereigns, aren't they? Are state
governments different sovereigns? I
think that what we're seeing right now
is that a lot of state governments are
abiding hookline and sinker with the
Trump administration. I think that's one
of the biggest topics that we've been
talking about over the last couple
months. Where are you?
>> Yes. Now,
yes, it is about elections.
>> First, first in the context of election
results, by which you mean the count of
votes, right? In the in terms of the
counts of votes, I'm not aware of
Republican states uh doing fraudulent
ballots that said we should question
their election results. And I don't
think that there's a track record of
that in such I wouldn't for in the
context of of state elections. That's
perfectly rational. What's the next
question?
>> I think what I think what you're doing
is you're you're cycling in and cycling
out to get away from the fundamental
question. And the question is, this is
number five, by the way. I brought it up
before. Number five, how wide is your
net? Where do you draw the line? Because
so far your only justification is
whether I like it or not.
>> No, no, no. That is not the only
justification. I just want to make sure
Wick, you hear me when I give the
explanation to the extent of the scope
of this negative inference.
>> Okay. So, I'm not just saying whether I
like it or not. Okay. So, reason number
one, if there is a track record in a
specific domain of government action,
all right, here in the context of
investigations, See, I don't know why
Pisco I feel like what I said is way
easier to understand than what Pisco is
saying. I just wish he'd say what I
said. Like obviously there's a bunch of
reasons to believe that the actions of
this government, especially with regards
to subpoena and judicial power, is
questionable. And that same thing
doesn't exist for the non-federal
government, the state the state bodies
that run elections. That's how you talk
about it, right?
>> Right. That that's what government
investigations. If there is a consistent
track record of lies and corruption,
that's one reason to apply negative
inference. That isn't just because I
like it, right? That's not that
>> I You You're saying uh generally
speaking, you're
>> Oh, never mind. Pisco laying it out this
way is going to make it very clear to
this guy that he can't argue. I see.
>> Defining your realm as investigations.
Yes, that's what you're wondering.
You're saying you don't like it?
Investigations is so broad that covers
100,000 people.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Did I say Did I say I
don't like it or did I say if there's a
track record of consistent lies and
corruption or is that the same thing as
I like it?
>> No. No. However, what uh what you are
saying as I hear
>> Okay. Wick, could you tell your guest to
open his ears and use his brain? Could
you tell your guest to stop being a to
stop wasting my time? Stop pretending he
doesn't understand. He understands. Ask
your guest, Wick, to like turn his
camera back on and slap himself in the
face. Wick, if you want me to continue
arguing, ask your guest to turn his
camera back on and slap himself in the
face now because I believe that is the
only thing that could wake him up and
get him to join the conversation and
start paying attention. Thank you. Thank
you, Wick. spirit is that you think that
the uh Trump administration has uh used
over and over and over again uh the
judicial branch in order to fulfill its
political goals in a way that you feel
is improper or corrupt and therefore
because they have a pattern of behavior
that we should
>> by default oppose whatever they do with
>> all into question he didn't say
necessarily oppose to be clear
>> I said you should a negative inference
>> negative inference and and so the the
reason I do this is I mean everyone
understands in their daily life if you
have someone who consistently you over a
student who consistently you know turns
in the wrong paper, someone who
consistently lies to you, a news source,
by example, uh think like Iranian state
media that consistently lies or or North
Korean state media. This is not
something bizarre to apply once you've
been shown to be so unreliable and so uh
you know corrupt that yes, this is not
something that's insane to apply and it
doesn't make you an election denier to
apply negative inference.
>> What's the difference between that and
extra scrutiny? Because you made it
clear that that's not what you're
saying.
>> Yeah. So the difference between extra
Yeah. I understand extra scrutiny to be
uh maintain a position of agnosticism,
right? an agnostic position and before
you're going to be swayed in favor to
have an extra threshold. That's what I I
take to be uh someone with extra
scrutiny when I'm fighting over nothing
because sorry no
so so so that's not the same thing
because that's not what I'm advocating
for. I'm not advocating for you. I'm not
So they're different. So we don't agree,
right? So they're different so we don't
agree, [laughter] right? I'm not
advocating for you to be agnostic and
just apply a higher threshold before you
believe it. I'm saying negative
disposition. No, wait. So these are
different positions, aren't they?
They're they're not because the whole
reason why
>> they're they're the reason the reason
why they're different is the reason why
you would apply extra scrutiny to
something is because you don't believe
it.
>> Do you understand the difference between
agnosticism and not
>> No, this guy uh
No, it's not that you don't believe it.
Although I would say that's like my
default position, but it's not quite
that. It's not quite that. Right. If I
could identify something independently
that was true, I wouldn't really
question it. when it seems dubious, when
it's targeting the Trump
administration's enemies, and it seems
like slightly dubious, when you could
see that it's not being applied evenly,
that's when the negative in inference
would lead to you going, "Yeah, I don't
believe this. Yeah, I don't I don't
think this is real. I don't think this
is serious." Right? What I would say is
it makes sense to have the negative
inference here and and nothing is
overcoming that negative inference. I'll
back it up.
>> Negative disposition. No, wait. So,
these are different positions, aren't
they?
>> They're they're not.
>> Oh, yes. It doesn't mean that you can't
believe the Trump administration is
doing something legitimate. That's why I
said the thing about like obviously you
could independently verify that like
Charlie Kirk was murdered. So there
needs to be an investigation into
somebody there, Tyler Robinson for
example, right? We there are some
independent verifiable fact that allows
me to go, "Oh yeah, sure. This obviously
needs to be investigated."
>> So the whole reason why
>> there the reason the reason why they're
different is the reason why you would
apply extra scrutiny to something is
because you don't believe it.
Do you understand the difference between
agnosticism and not agnosticism?
>> Yes, obviously. But what I'm saying, you
you are intentionally applying a neutral
tone to an investigation. In fact, a
reinvestigation. And what I'm saying is
that the whole reason to have extra
scrutiny, and this is this is just we
could chalk this up to me not
communicating it well enough. But the
the the whole reason to have extra
scrutiny is because you don't believe it
in the first place.
>> Yeah. So, I'm going a step further,
right? So, like
So, so I'll tell you why. I'll tell you
why. Right. Like there is a position
that you could take and that position is
in favor. You could take a position that
is against and you could take a position
that is I don't really know. I'm
agnostic. I I withhold judgment. Right?
Those are all different positions you
can take. I understand a position of
requiring extra scrutiny to believe
something to be a position ultimately
the grounds out into agnosticism. You
see that that's different than being
against it. I default against it in in
these domain.
>> I I'm not describing agnosticism. I'm
saying initially I do not believe that
this is true. So I will apply extra
scrutiny.
>> Oh. So are you an election denier?
>> I dude. Dude, [screaming]
dude, what is wrong with this guy? How
did he not see what he was JUST HOW DID
HE NOT JUST SEE WHAT HE'S WALKING INTO?
>> This is This is my point though. I I
like when you accuse me. Now we got the
same [laughter]
when you accuse me of We actually have
the same position. Bishop,
>> I was You were leading me to believe
that you were arguing something further
than extra scrutiny. I'm not even I am
like
>> No, Bishop, think of it like you're like
[laughter] if you're a debate moderator,
you're going to take everything they say
with extra scrutiny if you're trying to
fact check it. Even if like you're third
person or like if you're not like let's
say Caitlin Collins is trying to like
fact checker is trying to do extra
scrutiny to make sure all the debate
people are like telling the truth but if
you're uh doing a piece that's not
that's not quite true like if Rob Moore
tells me something I'm going to have
extra scrutiny for it but I generally
believe something negative
>> inference but also say [laughter]
no but the difference
what what what makes this thing is I
started off disbelieving the judicial
actions by the Trump administration
against this on I thought this is and I
told people this right I think this
like this doesn't seem to be something
that there is a legitimate case for.
However, the argument made today has
reminded me and I've looked into it more
and things like that where okay,
actually there's enough of a
plausibility here. It's high highly
likely that I have gone from being
against Trump to neutral in the
situation. I'm not pro,
>> but I am now neutral. I now I [laughter]
don't have enough information. No, you
started started with something I've been
wanting to say for a while. I'm I'm so
sorry, Fishy. This is something I've
been wanting to say for a while. I
really wish that I could take the soy
pill's entire perspective on this issue
because I would say philosophically I
started from where the soy pill is. The
problem is that with my experience and
knowing how a lot of this stuff works, I
find it virtually impossible that he
didn't talk to somebody and have a
conversation worth worth asking about. I
would say if I look, if I was in an
intelligence officer and my job was like
the Cuba desk, I would want to question
every single American that is coming in
and out of there right now. If anything,
just to be like,
>> why didn't they do that, Bishop? Yeah,
but they didn't do that. This is
mandatory process. This is
>> You're right. But the I say a political
program raises the threshold from your
average person.
>> No, no. I'm saying you could have you
could have asked about it. You could
have sent an inquir. You could have sent
him a letter. You could have sent a
subpoena.
>> No, a subpoena has a force of law. It's
a mandator. [laughter]
>> Okay. Like that's what I'm talking
about. If it was up to me, I I would I
would want to talk to every single
person. However, I think that the
threshold can rise when you are doing a
political program that is officially
collaborating with the Cuban government.
This isn't like my friend uh Tyler Panel
whose uh whose wife is from Cuba and he
regularly goes to Cuba and they just go
into and visit his family. This was a
this was an entire uh political program.
>> Wait, how do you know they're not how do
you know he's not doing that?
>> I I I I know that he's not in a
political program that has been
ordained.
>> How do you know? There's less reason to
suspect that.
>> Okay. Shouldn't we shouldn't we subpoena
him? Is it not plausible that he went to
a bar and talked to someone?
>> Once again, I think that there is value
in talking to every single person. I'd
be curious and be like, "Hey,
why?" Yeah. Why? Why don't we just
subpoena all of us?
>> What is this question? You guys are
playing stupid. I've said it four times
and it's so it's like I'm talking to
people that are intentionally acting
like they don't know what I'm talking
about. No, no, you can you can talk to
people. No one's stopping you from
talking to Hassan or talking to all
these people, but what happened was
there was an issuance of a subpoena and
at least allegedly there was
pre-clarance with the Office of Foreign
Asset Controls. And in that context, I'm
just not sure what what you're saying is
well, there's an interest in talking to
people. Why is that as which could be
true of anyone traveling to Cuba? Why is
that justification for the issuance of a
subpoena if it I mean the greater
includes the lesser here? Why wouldn't
it justify his opinion everyone who goes
to Cuba anytime?
>> I think I think I think he wants to
right if you want to sub
>> you would want a subpoena.
>> Okay, but that's not the position of the
Trump administration of Nick Shirley.
>> Every single individual.
>> No, I wouldn't want to subpoena.
>> Surely surely something distinguishes
this. I would want I would certainly I
would want to talk to every single
person that goes there and I would want
to subpoena anybody that is involved in
high level political programs deeply
involved with the Cuban government and
military. Yeah, absolutely.
>> As a
gohead, sorry.
>> No, no, no. That's what you're saying.
>> I was going to say like if if what you
take is that there's like a default
presumption that if you go into high
level communications with members of the
Cuban uh I don't know government or
whatever.
>> Yeah. So, I mean, if that's your view,
is there maybe there's evidence that
Hassan had high level communications and
you would therefore want to subpoena him
instead of like asking him about it or
send him a letter or saying sending a
request for documents? Um, I mean, I
just don't think that this is a standard
that the administration is actually
applying. I think what the administr I
think there's no question that if Hassan
were someone that were sympathetic
>> and basically would just need evidence
that that's the standard they are
applying, which actually I think might
have come out since this interview
started or since like in the past couple
hours, somebody who's saying that they
basically haven't sent any subpoenas.
They've done a request for documents
essentially, which to me I'm like, okay,
that seems that seems kind of fine if
it's not like compelled. Okay. Okay.
>> He would not be hit with a subpoena. And
I take politically motivated
investigations to be repugnant to the
constitution. And that's something
>> So are you are you asserting that there
is no difference between Hassan going to
Cuba and my friend Tyler Panell visiting
his f his wife's family?
>> I'm sure there's no difference. Why did
you say I'm sure I didn't say that there
was no difference. In fact, the reason
in fact I'm saying the opposite, right?
I said that there is a difference and
the difference is right and this is one
that I I think is obvious is their
sympathies towards the president. Their
sympathies
>> so I would I would say that a more
important difference is that one of them
was in an official program that was
collaborating with a hostile foreign
government and the other one isn't.
That's that's what
>> Hey, why why didn't they subpoena Brian
Grim?
>> Brian Grim? I I didn't do that.
>> I don't Yeah, Brian Graham.
>> No, I I don't know why they didn't
subpoena every single person on that
program.
>> Being a journalist, so I feel like that
would be
Well, journalist couldn't possibly talk
to a guy in a bar. That'd be great.
>> What's the difference between Brian
Graham and Hassan? Why didn't they? He's
a leftist. He's a leftist.
>> There's honestly not as big of an
influencer, I think, as big. They're
like, "Hey, we can we can go after these
people, right?
>> This is this but this is like if your
position
>> to be honest, I wouldn't be shocked if
somebody Fox got a heads up about some
like an investigation into Code Pink and
threw Hassan Piker's name in there just
to get keep him in the news cycle just
because like, hey, there's a lot of
interest for these Hassan [__] stories.
Can we work him? Can we just throw him
in here? You know, we'll just throw him
in here real quick.
>> Is that the Trump admin?
>> I would love to see Maybe we have to go
back and check because I think I have
the article from yesterday. Can I go
check the language on that article? What
is it saying? Uh an inside source is
alleging that
right. What's the language on the
article? Is it strong language or is it
very very very weak language of like
possibly it is becoming there is an
early source reporting that possibly
maybe in some university or sorry some
universe
how did I say university I'm I'm trying
to read and talk I'm reading chat and
talking at the same time never a good
combination
>> cracking down on it political opponents
and trying to chill anyone from going to
Cuba or helping Cuba and also using it
as a vector to attack its political
opponents Ryan Grim certainly qualifies
as a political component that they want
to attack and a vector to chill people.
So the question you have to deal with
and not I'm happy to answer that. Yeah.
For the same reason in the context of
what they did previously with
immigration and going after Mahmud
Khalil and going after Amaze Auster
because you don't have to get everybody.
You can go after particular targets and
you go after people who are
unsympathetic. Hassan is more
unsympathetic than Ryan Grim. Ryan Grim
has the extra extra credentials of being
a real journalist. I mean let's be
honest here. Uh Han is not a journalist
and there's probably more of an
institutional protection of them and so
yeah they go after weaker targets that
have
>> Wow. Wow. Impuging impugning the
journalistic credit of my guy Hassan
[__] this group of libs peo
I see how it is I see how it is man
>> less sympathy uh coding people right
those aren't sympathetic people to most
individuals in the country and so all of
that I think explains why you pick and
choose your targets and that doesn't
mean that it's not chilling right
anymore liberals are more likely to be
like you know what I am okay with them
going after that's the exact reason
you're liberals be okay with them going
after Ryan Grim and some of the other
tech I think you get a lot I think Ryan
Grim would get a lot more push back from
the liberals and they did this because
That's crazy.
>> No, I I [laughter] don't think you think
Assan is less or equally as hated as
Ryan Grim.
>> I think he is.
>> But if they're still in no for me, and I
can only speak for me. I think that Ryan
Grim is far more insidious than for a
lot of reason.
>> I think it's not about what you think is
more is worse. Right.
>> Most Americans don't even know who
Hassan is.
>> People know who is than Ryan Grim. More
people he's more famous than Ryan Grim.
A lot of these cases you you've created
a disprovable scenario based on what
follower count.
>> I don't No, no.
>> Now we're talking about disprovable
scenarios. Mr. Got met in a bar and
exchange intelligence.
>> No, [laughter] this is what I'm saying.
This is what I'm saying. You're there is
no impossible standard. As a fact of
life, Hassan told people that he was in
direct communication with the Cuban
government. That is something he said.
>> When did he say that?
>> This is not
>> direct. He's in direct communication
with the Cuban government through a
proxy. I like okay actually I don't even
know if it's just one proxy because like
I I do believe if that's going through
the like OFAC as well if all
communications are going through a
government approved entity then is that
a problem
>> he said so he can get his internet right
>> yeah he and let me let me rephrase that
in some kinds of legal terms he is in
direct communication with the Cuban
government to receive privileges
>> fact is it a fact that Nick Shirley was
in a sanctioned hotel he wasn't supposed
to be in
>> fact well don't get me wrong if you want
to sit here and tell me that this dog
government is not going after Nick
Shirley when they should be. I'll agree
with you all day. That [laughter] is not
contention.
If you if you grant that though, if you
grant that they're not applying the law
equally, that's repugnant to the
Constitution. That's repugnant to rule
and equal protection and and we should
be against the whole thing to put
nothing.
>> That's not how it works. It's like so so
if they if they wrongly investigate,
they stalk somebody day and night for
four years because they're trying to get
him for murder and then they get him for
murder and that was wrong because they
stalked him for four years. All of a
sudden we can't have problem with murder
as a whole. No absent absent abs absent
compelling evidence that distinguishes
the cases. Absent ev compelling
corroborating evidence. I am going to
apply negative inference to this regime
and and until they show me that the way
in which you know object an objectively
neutral person might distinguish the
conduct here. I'm going to assume that
they didn't have an objectively good
reason to objectively
>> what's up.
>> I was going to say this. I was going to
say wick the way you described your like
thing was 100% what Pisco said. But I
wanted to say I honestly if they they
didn't do it for China which was weird
but my thing is weird. If they did for
China or Cuba, I would be like, "Okay, I
kind of get some validity."
>> Because they want to do war with Cuba. I
mean, isn't that the most obvious thing
in the world?
>> I mean, they do want to go to war with
Cuba right now. And maybe that is
another reason that a subpoena or
request for documents could make sense.
>> And that's why they're doing they're all
trying to not get like trying to have
the upper hand on you. But if you went
to like if you went to like uh Ukraine
and they did this, I'd be like, "Okay,
that's wild." But I feel like the two I
feel like if you did it for China or
Cuba, I was like, "Okay, I definitely
understand some type of
>> They didn't do it for both." actually is
to me uh kind of pushes me towards that
there is something legitimate here if
their purpose was to target Hassan
[__] right? They would have done it
after he came from the CCP, right?
>> Everybody would have everybody would
have said he deserved it after he came
back from China. A sound bite of him
saying I'm not particularly patriotic to
the United States. Are you kidding me?
>> Vishy, we're going to clean it up. I
love you, BUDDY. BUT TWO BUCKS two bucks
ain't enough.
>> So So So let's talk about that, right?
You're saying this is not political
because I mean they didn't.
>> Does the US restrict restrict where you
stay in China? Is there a list of
pre-approved hotels and for you to stay
in in China? Is that a thing that exists
in China?
Cuz I could have sworn that that the US
trades happily with China, that there is
no embargo on China. Doesn't that imply
like a very very very different
relationship with China where you
wouldn't be able to apply anything like
this? Like, isn't it totally moronic to
pretend that the same investigation
would happen because you went to China?
>> I'm not saying that. I'm saying that for
me, for me, right, I do not know and I
do not have enough information to make a
legitimate decision here. And what has
pushed me towards that is again I start
from the position that whatever Trump is
doing is corrupt when it comes to the
judicial system. That's my starting
point. But there has been enough uh
stuff to kind of push me to the side of
well now I'm I'm unsure. And one of
those,
>> wait, to be clear, wait,
>> dude. The Justice Department is opening
a criminal investigation on Eene Carols
of 3 hours ago. It turns out Trump, they
really do like it when you grab them by
the or they go to jail. If you don't
like it when I grab you by the you're
going to jail, get ready for it,
>> dude.
>> Wait. No. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
You move
probably or might not be doing something
illegitimate because there's a plausible
scenario where this could be okay. Not
maybe Trump is illegitimate. And also
there's a plausible thing because that's
my position.
>> I think it's likely. It's not just
plausible to me. I think it's likely.
It's 60/40 if they wanted to chill uh
people uh having positive relations with
Cuba or having a positive view of Cuba
or helping Cuba in these ways. They
would have gone after everyone there
most likely.
>> No, that's not true. Wait. So when they
went after law firms, did they go after
every single law firm? They went after
Trump's enemies. They did. Every single
one.
>> No, they didn't. No, that's not what
occurred. No, they they they picked and
choose the ones either that Trump hated
the most or for whatever reason were
more outfront in terms of their
opposition or let's say they helped
Hillary Clinton on a matter and when
they did that other firms that weren't
specifically targeted were
>> Dude, if only there were ways to tell
that these people's political opinion
was worthless before this doobie. Oh my
god. Like when they totally disavowed
somebody for violating their friends and
then crawled back to them when they
realized they couldn't make it as a
streamer over time.
>> Like maybe that one. I don't know.
And that's also true who saw what was
happening to Harvard and other schools
and you didn't need to go after every
single school to get compliance. Same
thing by the way when it came to
immigration did they need to go after
every single green card holder who
criticized um the Israel policy? No.
They picked and choose and everyone else
got the message. And for you to say,
well, in order for me to think that
that's their need to go after similar
way people, you're really dumbing it
down. You're really dumbing it down.
You're just you're you're you're dumbing
it down by removing a lot of variables
and factors and you're just you're
essentially saying that, oh well, when
they went after the law firms, they just
went after a couple of them. It's like
no, there was factors there factors and
variables that went into who they target
and why they target. For example, as we
discussed before and with Hassan that
there are variables and factors that
differentiate Hassan from other people
that go beyond his follower count.
>> So So I I'm really just trying to get
you guys to understand the one singular
point I'm making here, which is the
following, right? Just because you
haven't shown that they've attempted to
uh do a specific action as to people who
are similarly situated doesn't mean that
they're not trying to chill. No, it
doesn't necessarily mean that, but I
think that it suggests to me that it
might be the case.
>> Yes.
>> Why Why does it move the needle on you
at all if they've picked two test cases
the same way, by the way, that they've
done in other instances before?
>> Because I see I see no I see no
significant
>> It looks like we're 5 minutes away from
Lykan hopping in. I'm not sure where the
argument goes. We'll see.
>> Downside for them to just subpoenaing
the meal. Like I see no significant
political hit that they would take from
doing that. There would be no downside
to doing that. Yeah, there going
>> there's not a huge outrage about this.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes, there is. What are you talking
about? There's like a whole like media
swing and if you think if they didn't go
after more journalists who had more
evidence
hated as a biker that they wouldn't get
more push back, I don't think there
would be any more.
>> I think your intuition here is
incorrect. I think that if they had gone
after every single person on that
flotilla that that needle wouldn't have
moved in any significant
>> really that's I mean
a strong
>> it would just be the exact same if they
went after everybody in that flotilla.
It' be the exact same guys.
Why do you think that?
>> So it does apply in the situation that
the more you paint with so the more
people that you you get involved the
less likely that you're going to have uh
you know a unified opposition against
you know particular individuals because
those people have their own networks
have no all I'm trying to tell you is
that it's true on both inferences. It's
true on both worlds. It's true in the
world in which they're chilling that
they might not go after everybody and
it's true in the world in which they're
not chilling that they might not go
after everybody. Right. So everything
you've said are neutral to meal
evidence. Wick wick wick. Do you think
they're trying to create a media
chilling effect? Do you think they're
trying to create a media chilling effect
when they go after Jimmy Kimmel?
>> Just Jimmy Kimmel?
>> Yes.
>> Why? It's just Jimmy Kimmel.
>> Yeah, it's just Jimmy
>> because he's not just Jimmy Kimmel to be
clear. They've gone
>> No. What do you mean the thing? A bunch
of people said a bunch of trust, but
they just went after Jimmy Kimmel. So I
mean like right like it's just because
the line, right? Again, there's no
legitimate case for this in but in the
>> in the instance here there is
>> this is once again I I can't paint I
can't paint a scenario for you right now
that something that Jimmy Kimmel said
might have incited violence that there
is a much no grant you that do you think
there's a scenario that Jimmy Kimmel
might have said something that a show
host Wick do you think that Jimmy Kimmel
could have said something that incited
violence against Republicans
>> not in any meaningful
not a plausible scenario not a single by
the way that's not what anybody says is
obviously you are incurring some
increased risk of somebody getting shot
in the head when you call them a
fascist. The issue is what what
trade-off is more important to you. If I
call you a fascist and I mean it
sincerely and I lay out reasons I think
you're a fascist and obviously the
implication of fascist is like Nazi
Germany uh our enemies. I am obviously
doing that. The unfortunate thing is so
long as it's descriptively true, so long
as I'm accurately describing you
and on top of accurately describing you,
I believe it like that is more
important. Preserving my right to that
speech is more important than not
increasing that risk very very slightly.
Right now, I don't think it's a big
risk. I don't think you add very much to
the risk. You certainly can't be held
responsible for somebody taking that
action, especially when you principally
disavow that action. But of course there
is some tiny tiny tiny piece where you
are increasing that when you say
something like that, right? The issue is
the world where you let that prevent you
from speaking the truth is a world you
don't want to live in.
>> I did not say I did not say equal.
>> Yeah, exactly. I could say man that
Trump guy really stinks. And probably in
some tiny minuscule infantismally small
way I'm probably increasing the chance
that somebody blows Trump's head off.
But I'm not I don't. I think that's
awful. I don't I would never suggest
that. It is both morally and
pragmatically repugnant and terrible and
and awful for your movement to even lean
into those things. Okay. I
>> prolific.
>> What if there were a trial of some kind?
[laughter]
>> Okay. I'm going to I'm going to mute all
of you unless you shut up right now. I'm
putting my moderate back hat on. Peace
go give your statement and then once
you've given
>> he's accusing me of bad faith and he has
no he has no basis to do that when I
said ape strong together. Clearly the
point there is to suggest that there are
downsides to going too far and getting
people who and instead of isolating
individuals who can be uh chilling
targets. That's what that statement
meant. There's nothing bad faith about
it. You just can't contend with the
arguments.
>> That's that is that shows how small your
mind is that you think I can't contend
with that. It is a [laughter]
[gasps]
>> Yes, that's my strategy. I just called
the other person a first. You're just
too dumb to understand me. THAT'S MY
STRATEGY. LET'S GO. I'm back on the
Lockheed liberal side. People [laughter]
thought it was bad. It is bad faith
because you could say that about
anything.
>> I have to let Bush respond
uninterrupted. Go ahead.
>> You could say that about literally
anything. It has no there is no value
there. There is nowhere for that
conversation to go. There is no there is
no response to that. There's no
analysis. That's why I said I don't even
want to talk about
Bishop. That was a Bishop. What was a
response to you all saying there's no
plausible reason why they would avoid
subpoenaing everyone there?
>> No plausible less plausible.
>> Yes.
>> Well, I I don't know how you make that
determination, but basically that
there's no cost entailed in subpoenaing
more of these people. Yes, that's my
intuition.
>> Yes. So, you guys had you guys succeeded
that there's no real cost. There's no
significant cost in painting with and
getting all these people and subpoening
them. And what I responded to is
actually isolating people is quite
effective. A strong together. The more
people you have, the more likely you're
going to get them to rally up against
you. That was the response there. I'm
not trying to say that that's what you
would I'm trying to say that it's your
false contention that there is no
strategic advantage to isolation. That's
what I'm trying to get at and it's a
responsibility.
>> What are what do they gain by isolating
Hassan?
>> Of course.
>> You think that it is easier to go after
an individual and not have to defend why
you're going after every single person
if they all have different reasons,
different backgrounds and different like
characters that need to be defended? Do
you think it's not easier to pick the
easiest weakest person who has the most
reason to be attacked for other reasons
like that the administration has gone
after? You don't think that's easier
than if you went after literally every
single person? easiest person. The
weakest attack. The easiest weakest
person on that trip is somebody that we
couldn't even name on this panel. The
idea that might make no no easiest
weakest in regards to they're the
easiest to attack. They're the easiest
target because they have all this smoke
against them. Even Democrats are going
against Assa for very
effect. Wouldn't Wouldn't it be a
chilling attack if they if they went
after a bunch of non-millionaires and
said Trump administration is persecuting
large swats? Because that's harder for
them to defend.
>> It's harder for them to defend. If you
did Yes. If you did all of them. It's
not. It's literally not against Hassan.
Wait, this is first of all, you can
disagree with this position.
>> The entire reason they're doing this is
dude, I don't even think they have any
intention to like go after the like
Hassan really. I truly believe this
might just be Fox News.
The reason they're picking Hassan is
because it's Hassan. That's why they
want Hassan.
>> But what I take issue with is your
notion that it's bad faith. It's bad
faith to say that there could be
interrupting and go after Hassan [__]
You've been interrupting and talking
over people and using bad faith
arguments since a
>> guy's getting aped and he doesn't like
it.
>> You got in here one bad argument,
>> dude. Dude, this guy got so
obliterated on the Oh, are you election
Are you an election denier? He got so
obliterated by that he can't handle